- So at this point,
anyone who would
like to ask a question to
any and all of the speakers
should line up behind
the microphone.
And can we have
your name, please?
- Hi, I'm Evelyn
[? Ginsberg. ?] This
is a basic genetic question.
If we share 99 point
something percent of our genes
with chimpanzees, but my distant
cousins on 23andMe share 2%,
is this a different
counting system?
How are we counting what
percentage of genes match?
- Who's going to answer that?
- I can try to speak to that
since I brought up the factoid.
So 99.9% of your DNA is the
same as, say, your neighbors,
or somebody across the planet.
That said, that
fraction that varies
tells us a lot
about inheritance.
So if you're looking between
you versus one of your parents,
you will share 50% of the
variable sites in your DNA
with your parents.
And then if you start to
look back further and further
in time, say, look
at your grandparents,
you'll share on average about a
quarter of your variable sites
in your DNA with
your grandparents.
So it's a difference between
what's varying generally
in the population versus what
varies across enormous time
scales.
- So it's the variation
between different humans,
assuming that you've found all
the variation that there is?
- Yeah, that's right.
And this is due to
common variation, not
these super, super rare
individual specific variants
that are arising very newly
within the population.
- So it's some small subset
of all possible genes
that you're measuring
when you say we have
2% in common with Neanderthals.
- Yeah, so that refers
to what fraction
of your genetic ancestry traces
itself to the Neanderthals.
So the 2% number
says, essentially you
can think of every
point in your genome,
you can trace its ancestors.
And so you have many
such genetic ancestors.
And of those set of
genetic ancestors, about 2%
will trace their ancestry
to the Neanderthal lineage.
So that's really what
we mean when we talk
about 2% Neanderthal ancestry.
- I'm not sure I understand.
2% of the entire genome,
counting every single DNA pair?
- So it's the ancestry
along of your genome.
So for example, when
you're looking at parents,
right, so that is genetic
ancestry that's immediate.
But then when you go
to the next generation,
you have your
grandparents, and there
are four possible ancestors.
And they can contribute
different amounts
of genetic material to
different parts of your genome.
- Oh, so it's 2% of the tree?
- So the way to
think about it is,
if you take one
point in your genome,
and you go to your parent--
so you inherit it from
one of your parents.
And then you follow which parent
that parent inherited it from,
and you keep going
all the way back.
So you will, at some point,
maybe 50,000 years back,
you will either go
to the Neanderthal,
or you will go to
the modern human.
So this is for one
point in your genome.
Now, you go to another point,
and you repeat this process
and see which ancestor that
part of the genome traces
its ancestry to.
In general, they
need not be the same,
and this is because
of recombination.
So it keeps switching around
as you move along the genome.
And so that's where--
then you count it
up, and you ask,
what percentage comes
from Neanderthals?
On average, it's about 2%.
- Thank you.
Next.
- Hi.
My question is
for Alicia Martin.
And this problem, right, that
we have, it's not a new problem.
I think of it as sampling error,
where the data that we collect
and the conclusions that
we draw from it in medicine
have been around for
a really long time.
So this seems to me to be
an extension of a very, very
old problem, and the fact
that we draw conclusions
in ways which somehow don't
really take into account
what the actual sample is.
Do you have any
thoughts on how we
can go about correcting this?
- Yeah.
That's a great question.
Thanks.
Yeah, so to your
point, this problem
has been around for a long time.
It's been around as
long as genetics,
or even far before genetics
was being studied regularly
across populations.
So like a decade ago,
for example, researchers
said that 96% of participants
in genetic studies
were of European descent.
Now we're 80%.
So we're making some
progress, but of course it's
not fast enough.
And so I think the
ways that we need
to start enabling some parity in
these public health issues that
are going to start emerging
with the translation
of genetic technologies is
by enabling funding sources
to start to focus more outside
of European populations
than within European
populations.
I think we're also going
to need to encourage
more genetic
investment of resources
outside of Europe and the US.
Local researchers
are going to need
to take this up at scale within
different continents, as well.
I think this is going to need
to happen on a very large scale
globally.
But it's also important
to note that we're not
reflecting the diversity
that's present in the US.
So the US is also going to
need to step up and make sure
that the data access for some
very large, diverse cohorts
that already exist are
accessible to a globally
diverse community.
So there are some
very large cohorts
that are out there that capture
the breadth of diversity
in the US, where it's
actually really hard to access
genetic summary statistics.
And this isn't due to
any privacy concerns,
because genetic summary
data is exactly that.
It's summary data.
There's no individual
level privacy
concerns for that type of data.
So we also need to make sure
that we can access that.
So there's many
different moving parts
that all need to coalesce, I
think, to move towards parity.
And it's going to be
a very hard problem
that we need to start really
making concerted efforts to try
to address over the
coming many years.
- Just one quick follow
up, and that is, do you
think it would help to diversify
the professional community
of researchers doing the work?
- Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
It feels a little
ironic talking to some
of my more diverse
colleagues who
are studying European
participants at scale
as sort of the white girl
up here harping on the fact
that we need more
diverse participants
in genetic studies.
Of course that's the case.
And I think we certainly
need to diversify
the academic community.
But we also need to
encourage new leaders that
are invested in this
problem as something
that they're going to be
driving forward longer term.
So yeah, I absolutely
agree with that.
- Nick?
- I'm Nick Patterson.
I used to be at Broad, and I'm
at Harvard Evolutionary Biology
and Harvard Medical School.
And I just wanted to share with
you something I talked about
with Alicia, how
some of the minority
communities in this country
have not been treated well,
and there's a second order
effect on whether they
participate in studies.
So I just will share
with you, I was
involved in a medical study
of cardiovascular genetics
in African-Americans.
And the primary center of
the study was in Mississippi.
And we had a poorer
response than we
wanted from the
African-American community.
And a common question
we were asked
is, if we give you
our genetic data,
will that be available
to law enforcement?
And the legal answer is, under
subpoena, absolutely yes.
And it's hardly a secret that
the African-American community
in the deep south
and law enforcement
have not always
got on very well.
So the consequence was
that our participation
was lower than we wanted.
And so that's a
political problem
due to past political and
present political effects
in the United States.
And it's causing
technical difficulties
in acquiring the data
that Alicia wants to see.
So I just thought
I'd share that.
- Yeah, Nick, that's
an excellent point.
Thank you so much
for bringing that up.
I forgot to mention that,
absolutely, the mistrust that
happens in academic
research is often
earned through
historical misuse of data
or through historical
tensions with law enforcement.
That's absolutely the case.
And I think to start to broach
some of these issues we need
to be very delicate about how
we start to communicate both
the needs for public health
purposes versus the tensions
with law enforcement
or with other bodies.
- Yes, Alyssa?
- Hi.
So I have my freshman
seminar students here today,
and they're taking a freshman
seminar about prediction.
And some people here know I
have a particular interest
in prediction.
And my long term dream is
that data science will help us
with climate change.
And so what does this
have to do with you?
The question is, I know
that in academia there
are a lot of silos.
And a lot of what you are
doing is obviously related
to what each other
are doing here, right?
And what I want to
know is, let's say
we're thinking about
a future where we're
going to have the ability
to really simulate
the future of the earth.
And we need to understand the
interaction of all four things
that you were talking about.
And how is the
climate forcing that?
And how are the fact that people
are eating tilapia, and ones
with Neanderthal DNA
are, and [INAUDIBLE],,
and then they're having clover
honey on it, and whatever else
they're doing.
So what venues are there
for you to exchange
your data and your ideas, other
than today, which is wonderful.
But in other words,
are there organizations
where people are thinking
about pooling the kind of data
and research that you all have
across your sub-disciplines
that all touch on evolution?
- Anybody can answer.
- Anybody answer that.
- I mean, I don't
know about the others,
but I'm a strong
proponent of open science.
I put all of my data
sets, all of my code,
drafts of my manuscript,
everything is just available
online even before publication.
Which might be a
pretty extreme route.
But I think, I
believe in just having
it out there for other
people to use and see.
Now, I know that's
not always the case,
especially if you're
dealing in human genetics
and you have samples that maybe
would violate some sort of law.
And you can't just put it out
on the internet for everybody
to have access to.
But at least nobody cares
about clover to that extent.
So I'm happy to put all of
my data and my code online,
and it's often helpful
for other people,
too, who are doing
similar things.
So at least in my case, I just
try to be as open as possible,
as I can, with the stuff that
I am doing and want to do,
and then hopefully
that fosters that sort
of open science type of idea
that you're talking about.
- And that, if I may, and that
is the problem right there,
a big portion of the problem
is that, the white clover,
who really cares?
But the implications for
humans, and of course tilapia
aside, is that we are
restricted by putting human data
or identified-- everything
is de-identified.
And it's not, from
my experience,
it's not so much that the
participants are worried
about what they put online.
It's really because of
the health insurance
discrimination.
There's other-- we
have to go deep,
and it's going to be more
than the two minutes that
are left in this
session, to uncover
why we can't have open access.
My experience is not because
there's not a willingness
to be transparent
and forthcoming
by the participants, but
they're hindered by forces
beyond themselves.
So I'm going to open
it up to the rest.
I didn't mean to
get on my soapbox.
But go on.
Anybody else?
Yes, Katie.
- Just one other note.
I think that that idea
requires us to really think
outside the box.
It's not only data
accessibility,
it's thinking about how we cross
disciplinary boundaries to make
those kinds of connections.
And I think that's a
persistent societal challenge.
I don't think that there is an
organization that does that,
but it requires
individual thinkers to be
willing to take those leaps.
- Yes, sir.
A few questions?
- Hi.
OK, I have a couple questions.
Number one, in your
talk, you mentioned
that there's 2% Neanderthal
DNA on average in a person.
And I noticed in
that graph where
you had the figure where you
had the amount of introgression
in, I think, East Asians
and some other populations,
the peaks were not overlapping.
So I'm just curious,
what's the total coverage
of Neanderthal peaks
across everyone?
So if I have 2--
well, I don't have 2%.
But if someone else has 2%,
and someone else has 2%,
that might be 3% total coverage.
Are they very overlapping, or
just completely everywhere?
- Yeah, so we tried to do
this experiment where we said,
let's say we took all of the
segments of Neanderthal DNA
across all the people
that we can identify.
Can we stitch them together?
And if you do that, how
much of the Neanderthal
do we actually recover
from present day people?
And so we recovered of the order
of around 60% of the genome.
Yeah.
So-- six-zero, in
terms of length.
So what that's telling you
is, at least one person has
a chunk of Neanderthal DNA that
you can use to stitch together
a full kind of genome.
And now you can
ask, I mean, there's
another question you can ask,
maybe how much further can we
get?
If we had a bigger sample
size, can we get closer?
And I think that's where
you run into these issues
of these deserts,
which nobody seems
to have Neanderthal DNA at.
And so I think they're kind
of saturating, literally,
how much of their genome
we can cover that way.
- OK, well, that's
already a surprise.
I thought it would be like 8%.
Is that a published
analysis, or is
that just like some experiment?
- It's published
in our 2014 paper.
- OK, sweet.
All right, second question,
because I was confused.
You had this argument of
constraints to justify--
actually, I completely forgot.
I just want you to re-explain
how constraint on evolution
helps you make arguments for
introgression events, sort
of re-explain.
- So I'm assuming you're talking
about what happens in regions
of the genome that
are constrained,
and how much Neanderthal DNA
is present in those regions?
- Yeah.
You just had some graphs that's
like constraints on the x-axis.
I just didn't understand that.
- Yeah, so there are some
regions of the genome,
for example, if you go close
to genes, which are functional
elements in the genome, that
tends to be more constrained.
So what that means is--
- No, yeah.
Yeah, I know what that means.
I'm just saying, how does that
play into the introgression?
- OK, so those are
places where there
is going to be stronger
selection on mutations
that are deleterious.
So for example, if you have
a Neanderthal chunk that
carries a deleterious
mutation, depending
on which part of the
genome you're looking at,
whether it's a more constrained
or a less constrained genome,
the selection is
going to be stronger
in one versus the other.
And so in the first case,
it gets removed quickly.
And so you're going to
see a reduction compared
to the second case.
- OK, cool.
And then, sorry, one
more question for Alicia.
- Can you save your
question for the reception?
We'll have a reception
downstairs right after,
and then you can
corner [INAUDIBLE]
and ask all the
questions you want.
I'm sorry.
If your question is quick?
- Yeah, really quick.
My name's Christina
Wilson, and I'm
thrilled by the
advances in research
that you all are doing.
But I also wonder
what you personally
feel like your obligations
are in a country like America
where, for instance,
health care is not
a guaranteed-- access to health
care is not a guaranteed right.
And what the implications of
essentially marking everyone's
pre-existing conditions from
birth, I think you said,
has on the sociopolitical
economic conditions that
may or may not be exacerbated.
One thing, to the organizers,
I would have loved
to see a bioethicist or a--
- We talked about that.
Sean, didn't you say during
the break that-- yes,
we've already taken that--
- Oh, great.
So that's fantastic.
But also personally,
I mean, we already
heard from James
that his philosophy
is put it all out there.
And you're dealing with clover.
But this happens in cities,
too, with open data in cities,
about technological points of
contact and similar things.
You have corporations
and for-profit industries
using this public data to
do what they will with.
So I'm just wondering
what, as scientists,
what your personal
sense of obligation
is to protecting the
rest of us living--
and being thrilled
by the discoveries,
but wanting to live a good life.
- Thank you.
Yeah, that was a
pretty big question.
So I think maybe we can start
to tag-team pieces of this.
So in thinking about how
genetics can mark you
from birth for
some traits or not,
I want to re-emphasize the
fact that genetics is not
deterministic, especially
for complex traits
that we're studying like
cardiovascular disease.
Of course, your
environmental effects
can be as big or more
important than some
of your genetic factors.
So I think it's, of
course, an important issue
to make sure that the
non-discrimination acts
in genetics continue
to be upheld.
We need to make sure
that that does not
go away at any point in time.
I think we need to
advocate to policymakers
that this is really important
as it stays separate from health
insurance companies.
All of those factors
are really important.
And then, to the open
science sense of camaraderie
that we all share,
I would emphasize
that, in human
genetics, while it's
hard to share
individual-level data,
we are also interested in
sharing summary data that
can be used for anybody
that's out there to compute
their own scores or start to
learn about their own biology.
So that's certainly
also out there
and accessible through a
lot of these public servers.
And we also put all
of our code out there,
and we also put all
of our manuscripts
on pre-print servers, so
that anyone can access them
as soon as we're in a state
to actually share them.
Yeah.
Does anyone else
want to add anything?
- Yeah, so I'm also part
of the same community,
and so again, I think
it's extremely useful
to have access to data.
So in human genetics,
a lot of the genotypes,
including the Neanderthal DNA,
that's publicly available.
You can access them.
You can search for them.
You can write your own
tools to query your DNA.
Harder when you overlay it with
free data of different kinds,
but that's where the
community has agreed
to the sharing of some
of these statistics,
and that's been a way of still
sharing data without getting
into these privacy issues.
And I think that's been
extremely valuable.
- So again, [INAUDIBLE]
that you're talking about
[INAUDIBLE] which is great,
talking about the bottom-up
effect of us taking that
knowledge that we now know
about our personal genome, like
taking a 23andMe or whatever,
and making changes
in our lifestyle.
But what I'm talking
about is a top-down.
And so being able, at a policy
level, or a corporate level,
to take that data and apply
it to mass populations.
[INAUDIBLE]
- OK, well, that is great
for reception discussion.
I would like to thank
wholeheartedly these four
fantastic rock stars.
[APPLAUSE]
Sriram, Alicia,
Katie, and James.
Thank you.
I am very optimistic.
The future is very bright.
Because these are early curious
scientists that will inform us
for many, many years to
come, years that Alyssa
and I will no longer be here--
no.
Didn't you take your 23andMe?
I'm kidding.
OK, with that, the reception
is on the first floor.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]